Vivian: When I was actually applying to Hillsdale,
the WHIP program was a major factor in wanting
to come to Hillsdale in the first place. I'm
an editorial intern, so every day I post
our website's videos. I write posts about foreign
policy, things that are going on in the Hill.
Especially from the journalism prospective
it's a unique city to be in because we have
congress and we have the White House, so it's
a really unique opportunity to actually go
to events where news in happening.
I think one of the best parts about being
on WHIP during the semester as opposed to being
the summer is that you get to take classes
with Hillsdale professors. You learn so much.
I'd definitely say that the time spent in
Washington, DC with the WHIP program is definitely
worth it. You still do have a community of
Hillsdale students in the area. It's really
easy to keep up with your friends with Skype
and Facebook and Twitter, so I would definitely
say that the investment is definitely worth it.